I know he was doing the watch before but
is it a bit surreal when you see NFL
players NBA players I mean all these
professional athletes showing the watch
right now we we're on a bigger stage
we're on a bigger stage first of all
much love and shout out to DJ Ked man
that he's shoot he's the one stamped it
you know when when khed stamps it is
it's it's 100 like when khed stamped it
and the Rick Ros stamped it you know
that's that's that's Hood royalty that's
that's the royalty of uh social media
not only that but that's is royalty man
so uh I love to see it it's hilarious to
me because he and I joke about it on a
daily basis we we just got to get him a
lucrative watch deal he can't keep doing
it for free he can't keep can't keep
doing it for nothing we got to
capitalize now he is my son we got to
capitalize on the moment right